the black Wall Street comes from the
Negro Wall fit of America which is a
term that was affixed to the community
according to lore by Booker T Washington
black Wall Street is in many ways a
misnomer because what what the business
community in the Greenwood district the
black community is also was like was
more like would be a black mainstream so
these were not you know banking
enterprises an investment these are
mostly small businesses so there were
movie theaters and dance halls and
barber shops and grocery stores and
restaurants and service providers like
doctors and lawyers and pharmacists and
dentists these are relatively well-off
black folks who contributed to the
economic forces of places like the
Greenwood district black Wall Street of
Tulsa like the successful black business
community of Muskogee Oklahoma and like
the successful small all block towns
that dotted Oklahoma during this period
the conditions were particularly
oppressive in the deep south places like
Alabama Mississippi so there were people
who came to Oklahoma during the land
openings beginning in 1889
african-american people who recruited
black folks to come from the deep south
Oklahoma really put the idea that they
could get a fair shake in Oklahoma a
number of notable figures taught it the
Greenwood district it's early
hey-ohh w girl is considered the father
of the Greenwood district he's a
relatively wealthy black man from
Arkansas who came to Oklahoma in the
land run in 1889 ended up in Tulsa 1906
he start his first business he owned the
girly hotel and had a grocery store as
as well he also bought land and sold to
other black folks in the community at
that time so in some senses he helped
populate the district so for those
reasons he's considered founder in the
end and the father of
the district Blackwall 3 the Greenwood
district was also a community of
necessity it wouldn't have been a need
for a separate black economic island in
Tulsa had not been for Jim Crow
segregation so black people were not
able to participate fully in the
mainstream economy dominated by white
tolson's so they created their own
economy this community thrived up until
the first devastation which was the
massacre many black families spent days
weeks and months living in tent cities
set up by the Red Cross
and the destruction was almost complete
property damage conservatively estimated
was one point five to two million
dollars again it's conservatively
estimated and that would translate today
well over twenty five million dollars it
is a complicated I would say we have
contacts that it is also implementing of
the racial violence that's a fuse the
United States during this period and
it's impossible to understand what
happened in Tulsa 1921 if you don't
appreciate the kind of systemic racism
that was operating in the country during
that period and thereafter the community
was rebuilt after that to a substantial
degree peaking in the 1940s early to mid
1940s with well over 200 documented
black on operated businesses but then
there was a second devastation this was
not a devastation effected through
violence but rather through policy so
generally black wealth is one tenth of
white wealth that's sort of the general
standard why is that it's because
the lack of the ability part of
african-americans to transfer wealth
intergenerationally because there are
barriers to that among the barrier so
these a these incidents like like the
one who tells of the massacre
it really obliterated black wealth that
would have otherwise transferred across
generations as Americans were not really
good about addressing hard history and
we're not really good about making sure
our textbooks include history that is is
is troubling particularly around race
and Tulsa in particular Tulsa was on an
upward trajectory in 1921 it was it went
on to become the self-described oil
capital of the world so the leaders
we're not really interested in in
promoting or including this history in
documents in fact they had an interest
in minimizing this history would Tulsa
have been Atlanta had it not been for
the massacre
because Atlanta is considered kind of
black Mecca it has meant for less it
feud a few decades the answer is of
course I don't know but and we'll never
know but it's but Sir certainly Tulsa
would be more advanced he cannot blame
them in terms of the black community had
it not been for that great disrupter
that was the festival I talk about the
black Wall Street mindset and that is
the endowment all human spirit
the sort of can-do attitude in the
economic and entrepreneurial realm and
that's what what resonates with me when
I think about black Wall Street is not
necessarily a geographic space
it's not a particular set of enterprises
it's a mindset and it's a mindset that
is malleable and portable
you